[Music]
yeah that's everyone doing the first
thing I have to say is thank you so much
for coming by
the only reason Collider gets to be at
the Toronto Film Festival is because the
sponsors want to give you a huge thank
you to Nordstrom Canada for letting us
be here being a great sponsor thank you
thank you and now jumping into why I get
to talk to you guys today so I hate to
it first of all congrats on the movie I
thought you guys did a great job with it
and I'm just curious almost everyone
watching this will not have seen it yet
so who wants to bite off the generic on
what the film is about
so Heather Graham plays the character
Cammie who is a single mother with her
teenage daughter played by Sophie and
after the you know the death of her
ex-husband she offers to take in Rachel
who's played by Jody and her daughter
Tallulah played by Abby into her home
when they find out that the ex-husband
was actually destitute so it's a story
of these women all put together under
one roof these mother daughter sets and
how they deal with grief how they try to
move forward how they grapple with each
other and how they they reckon like what
what their relationship was with this
man and their lives so it's all of this
stuff happening under one roof over one
summer one of the things that I really
took away that I really enjoyed is that
it no one ever gave what I call an
exposition dump in the movie like and
everyone sort of was like very it felt
very real like the characters and no one
you know what I mean like it was never
nothing ever felt fake in it so I'm just
curious talk a little bit about that
aspect of the script and maybe if that's
something that you appreciated about
your characters all of us but for me
those moments of when you get dealt a
great big chunk of exposition as an
actor to deliver as not exposition it's
like the worst thing ever
so to have your so write the script was
almost entirely devoid of that and I
think it's like it's the biggest gift
ever just to be able to exist in the
present moment and the present tense in
the scenes you're in just examining
human behavior and human relationships
without having to like come on audience
this way you know you don't have to do
that you can trust that an audience is
smart enough to follow along certainly
in this context anyway I think Ashley
made a movie about what people don't say
it's kind of like people's behavior says
more like your actions speak louder than
words so that's what I love about it too
and she would follow you around the
camera when you didn't have dialogue and
she caught these moments that aren't
dialogue driven just actions and
thinking what your characters are
thinking and the parts of themselves are
hiding from other people their private
lives are secrets go on more compliment
is also authentic to a point that we
would even sometimes ad-lib I remember
doing scenes in the car where she would
just let us be and just create by
ourselves and just be like how would you
feel in that moment so it wasn't always
even about what was written in the
script it's really the in the present
moment how we felt and how we thought
our characters would react which made us
think a lot as an actor because you
always I mean I tend to play what is
written but to actually put yourself in
a position of how you would react or how
your character would react made me think
even more and kind of going deeper into
what the character is and I just loved
that she gave us this Liberty to really
create oh yeah okay so I feel like
getting a lot of like lines and you have
to like kind of use those lines to tell
like the backstory or like who your
character is it's pretty hard kind of
like Jodie said it's it's hard because
you have to act like you're just saying
it without like trying to give a
backstory you're like oh this happened
and that happened and this happened but
I feel like um I feel like we we did
live a lot we did we did and I feel like
it's kind of easier to just kind of go
with go with what you think is saying
rather than being given a line and and
had to say that exact exact thing or had
to had to say something like that you
don't really feel is right and I
I want to ask you a specific question I
really enjoyed what you did with the
edit like it's it's quick moving it
never feels like wasted time so the
movies like an hour 20 minutes did you
ever feel like pressure from financers
or from anyone being like you know if
you make it an hour forty minutes or an
hour forty-five minutes
do you know what I mean there's I mean
the basically the way that we cut this
movie was like that was to give a little
bit but not to give everything the
emotion needs to come like these these
actors are you know filled with amazing
like amazing talent and are bringing the
bringing the emotion to the to the film
but the emotion that I want the audience
to feel I really want them to feel it
and not have to watch these women go
through it on screen so that's why we
get out of a scene really quickly and so
and and leave you hungry for that moment
that we're now taking you out of and
we're moving on you know because that's
their private moment that's we're
leaving them in that moment it's up to
your imagination which can be you know
wherever you feel you know at that at
that place so you know it's a different
style of cutting that's not necessarily
the most conventional so of course
there's always comments about like well
we'd love to just see a little bit more
of like of that like there's you know
there's the scene that we shot in the
motel where I mean Joe where Jody's
character is crying and there's we shot
a lot of crying sob and reach into these
depths of her soul to sob and cry and we
don't use much of that because it's like
when we when we leave her there you feel
it even more because we know that she's
alone in this moment and we're not there
watching her voyeuristically you know so
there was a couple of comments like that
and you know it there's a for having a
little bit extra breathing room in
certain spaces and that kind of thing
but it was how how I wanted the story to
be told so I like the pace I actually
think you did a great job with the Etta
so you may you know I say good job
because I'm basically out of time I just
want to ask real fast you guys are part
of the Toronto International Film
Festival what does it mean to be here
for you guys
and is there I guess let's do that like
what does it mean to be here because
it's this is my favorite festival it's a
big honour I mean this festival breaks
out independent movies and we I love
Anna pendant movies so I love when a
movie gets made and breaks through the
big studio system and gets seen like a
really great independent movie yeah it
really is special and not to say that
I'm super versed in the world's
offerings of film festivals but there's
something truly charming about TIF and
something that feels
despite its magnitude and its influence
there's a real sense of community here
and a real like film it feels like a
film lovers and a film nerds festival
sure um yeah I love being him same as
Jody being Canadian I always see have a
little I love this festival because it's
a Canadian festival so I'm always proud
to be here being from Montreal but I
just love how it's so grounded even
though it's like she said it's such a
huge festival you don't feel like it's
that big of a festival because there's a
lot of people but it's not too crowded
and people are so down to earth and
you're not rushed you're just really
living the moment and people are so
committed even just walking the streets
at night you see people that are sitting
down watching movies and just people
just really actually truly enjoy the
festival and I think it's one of the
most beautiful festivals I really do
like what Heather said it's a really big
honor to be here and I think it's so fun
and it's not like oh you have to go to
this festival you have to do this be on
time buh buh buh buh buh it's just yeah
but it's just really fun and it's an
awesome yeah sure it's a huge huge honor
and huge thrill to be here it's just one
of the greatest film festivals in the
world for all sorts of different types
of cinema and the town gets alive people
love people you know local locals love
seeing the movies and so that's really
exciting to be showing a film in a
festival that's also really part of the
fabric of the city and I'm also from
Montreal so I come here all the time and
it's really really I'm very proud of
having my movie premiere for the first
time
this festival in Canada with this
amazing cast of wonderful talented women
so it's yeah it's a over the moon again
I want to say congrats I think you I
thought you guys did a great job and
thank you so much for stopping in Thank
You Nordstrom Canada and enjoy your
party and the premiere and everything
that goes with it
and I'm watching you for being thank you